lo primero que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es dada la información que se
muestra en este triángulo determina las
incógnitas determinar esta longitud
designada por la letra a determinar esta
longitud en naranja ve calcular la
medida de este ángulo alfa en radiales
calcular la medida de este ángulo beta
que tenemos aquí en azul te invito a que
pongas pausa en el vídeo y dada la
información que se tiene del triángulo
calcule es los valores de las incógnitas
supongo que ya lo intentaste veamos cómo
podemos determinar estos valores
conocemos dos de los lados que son
iguales ambos miden dos unidades y
también conocemos este ángulo que mide
pitt hercios radiales algo que se me
ocurre aquí es que de entrada este es un
triángulo isósceles un triángulo
isósceles es un triángulo que tiene dos
lados congruentes entre sí así es que
este lado es congruente con este otro
lado lo cual significa que los ángulos
de la base los ángulos correspondientes
van a ser también congruentes este es
una propiedad de los triángulos
isósceles
y es que estos dos son congruentes los
dos ángulos de la base son congruentes
eso quiere decir entonces que beta
también es igual a pi tercios radiales
entonces beta aquí es igual a pi tercios
radiales ahora pensemos qué más podemos
intentar bien si sabemos que beta vale y
sobre tres y este ángulo también mide y
sobre tres podemos calcular todo este
ángulo en blanco que tenemos aquí ya me
molesté ángulo x entonces podemos
establecer que x más y tercios x más pi
tercios más y tercios los
correspondientes a beta tiene que ser
igual a aquí es pi tercios no pi medios
entonces sabemos que la suma de los
ángulos internos de un triángulo es
igual a 180 grados o equivalente mente
irradian es es decir esto tiene que ser
igual a ciudad yanes y ahora si
despejamos x bueno aquí
podrías a simple vista determinar qué es
peter cios pero si lo quieres hacer
sistemáticamente restamos dos veces y
tercios a ambos lados de la ecuación
así es que tendríamos que x es igual a
ti que lo voy a poner ya en términos de
tercios que sería tres y tercios y es lo
mismo que tres tercios menos pi tercios
y menos y tercios y esto cuánto nos da
tres tercios menos pi tercios menos pi
tercios esto es simplemente pi tercios
así es que x este ángulo que tenemos
aquí en blanco es igual a iu tercios
esto es interesante pues hemos
determinado que el triángulo en realidad
es equilátero pues dado que tenemos que
estos tres ángulos son iguales entonces
los tres lados son congruentes tenemos
un triángulo equilátero así es que si
este lado mide 2 este lado mide 2
eso significa que todo este lado todo
este lado todo este lado que tenemos
aquí la base mide 2
ahora qué más podemos intentar calcular
sabemos que este ángulo mide y sobre
tres radiales este ángulo beta también
sabemos que mide pi sobre 3 aquí tenemos
un ángulo recto que mide 90 grados
equivalente a pi sobre dos radiales
conocemos estos dos ángulos podemos
entonces calcular este ángulo alfa
tenemos así que alfa
más
y tercios
más este ángulo recto que mide 90 grados
y medios radiales más y no mejoro va a
ser en blanco vamos a ponerlo en blanco
más y medios esto tiene que ser igual y
acuérdate que estamos viendo este
triángulo rectángulo que tenemos aquí
cuya suma de ángulos internos tiene que
ser igual a 180 grados api radiales esto
es igual a ti y ahora vamos a despejar
alfa alfa es igual a pi deja de verlo a
poner de una vez el común denominador de
3 y 26 lo a poner en sextos esto es 3 pi
sextos
menos pi tercios a sextos esto es 2
sextos este peter si os lo hemos puesto
como dos peace éxitos y menos medios a
sextos que es 3 y sextos y esto es igual
a 6 - 2 - 3 me queda 1 esto es igual a
ti sextos
así es que alfa es igual a p
sextos vamos a escribirlo aquí arriba
alfa es igual a pi sobre 6 radiales este
ángulo de aquí es igual a pi sextos
radian es y lo que es interesante aquí
es que alfa es exactamente la mitad de
todo este ángulo que tenemos aquí así es
que si este ángulo mide alfa también
este ángulo de aquí me de alfa al sumar
y sextos + y sextos obtenemos pi tercios
y con eso podemos estar seguros que esta
línea es la bisectriz de este lado de la
base del triángulo que esta longitud que
esta longitud de aquí es equivalente a
esta longitud de acá
esta es la bisectriz del ángulo así es
que cuando tomamos se encuentra el otro
lado y este es un triángulo isósceles de
hecho ya podemos ver aquí que estos dos
triángulos son congruentes
aquí tenemos lado ángulo lado lado
ángulo lado estos dos son los lados
correspondientes
así es que tienen que ser congruentes
así es que si este lado me debe también
este lado me debe con lo cual tenemos
que b b es igual a 2 b más b es igual a
2 de donde obtenemos que b es igual a 1
b es igual a 1 y ahora con la
información que tenemos ya podemos
encontrar a usando el teorema de
pitágoras aquí tenemos un triángulo
rectángulo con lo cual al cuadrado más
de cuadrada más 1 al cuadrado es igual a
2 al cuadrado vamos a despejar a
cuadrada pasamos 1 cuadrado restando el
otro lado con lo cual a cuadrado es
igual 2 al cuadrado es 4 - 1 al cuadrado
a cuadrado es igual a 3 hemos restado 1
a ambos lados
ahora vamos a despejar y sacamos raíz
cuadrada a ambos lados con lo cual hemos
encontrado que a es igual a raíz
cuadrada de 3 si recuerda los triángulos
especiales de tus clases de geometría
aquí puedes reconocer que este es el
mismo triángulo de 30 60 y 90 grados
nada más que aquí lo tenemos en radiales
es el triángulo
dos tercios y pi medios radiales lo que
es exactamente lo mismo a 30 60 y 90
grados y vemos que tiene las propiedades
del triángulo 30 60 90 donde el cateto
más pequeño el cateto opuesto al ángulo
depp y sextos radiales tiene una
longitud que es la mitad de la
hipotenusa mientras que el cateto mayor
tiene una longitud que es raíz de tres
veces el cateto menor o el cateto que es
opuesto al ángulo de pi tercios radiales
tiene una longitud equivalente a raíz de
tres veces la longitud del cateto menor
así que ya pudimos determinar toda la
información que se requería para este
triángulo dado eso ahora quiero
determinar cuáles son seno coseno y
tangente de alfa así como lo va a ser
para alfa lo puedo hacer para beta de
hecho voy a dejar como ejercicio que tú
los de termines para beta empecemos
calculando seno de alfa te invito a que
le des pausa el vídeo de los cálculos
por tu cuenta tenemos que el seno de
alfa es igual al seno de pi sextos
es igual recuerda la definición de show
acá todas son para todas déjame poner
todas en un color distinto solo acá toda
su seno es cateto opuesto sobre
hipotenusa y el cateto opuesto de pi
sextos
es 1 sobre la hipotenusa que en este
caso vale 2 es decir un medio senodep y
sextos es igual a un medio ahora coseno
de alfa coseno de pi sextos
jose no es adyacente sobre hipotenusa
así es que jose no de y sextos es el
cateto adyacente que es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 3 sobre la hipotenusa que es
2 el cosep y sextos es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 3 sobre 2
finalmente la tangente de pi sextos
tangente de pi pi sextos
podemos calcularla como seno sobre
coseno o directamente con todas vamos a
calcular la contó a es el cateto puesto
que es 1 sobre el cateto adyacente que
es raíz cuadrada de 31 sobre raíz
cuadrada de 3 ahora si a ti no te gustan
los números irracionales el denominador
podemos multiplicar por raíz cuadrada de
3 sobre raíz cuadrada de 3 con lo cual
obtenemos raíz cuadrada de 3 sobre 3 y
ya hemos concluido hemos hecho mucho
trabajo hemos obtenido mucha información
sobre este triángulo que nos dieron